دخلت البلاد في صمتها الانتخابي لكن ثمه
ما يسمع في هذا المكان تحديدا في الولايات
الجنوبيه جنوب تركيا نحن الان في ولايه
كهرمان مرعش مركز الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
قبل اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر اشهر وخلف عشرات
القتلى ومئات الالاف من المصابين وايضا
النازحين كما نشاهد في الصوره اثار
الزلزال ما زالت باديه لكن عمليات الازاله
تمت بشكل كبير للانقاض هناك عمليات
متواصله
لهدم المباني الاله للسقوط هذا الوضع
الكارثي الذي تعرضت له ولايه كهرمان مرعش
وعشر ولايات اخرى في جنوب البلاد قد ينعكس
على العمليه الانتخابيه في ولايه كهرمان
مرعش هناك اكثر من 750 الف ناخب يحق لها
من التصويت في العمليه الانتخابيه مرعش
ولايه معروفه تاريخيا
بالتصويت الدائم لحزب العداله والتنميه
لكن بعد هذه الظروف وهذه
الكارثه التي مرت بالبلاد وايضا الظروف
الاقتصاديه الصعبه التي تمر بها البلاد
يبقى السؤال ان كان هؤلاء سيستمرون في
التصويت لحزب العداله والتنميه ام لا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات